Let's go through a simple example of type one and type two errors. Have you
ever sipped a beverage that was too hot, and you burned your tongue? Let's say
that the null hypothesis is that the beverage is fine to drink. It's not too
hot, it's perfect. The alternative hypothesis then, is that the beverage is too
hot to drink. So, now, four things can happen. One thing, which often happens
to me, because I'm hasty, is you decide the beverage is fine to drink but then
it's too hot and you burn your toungue. Another thing that could happen is you
decide that the beverage is fine to drink now and indeed it is, then you enjoy
drinking it. Another thing that can happen is you think the beverage is too hot
now so you wait until it cools but it's actually fine to drink, and then by the
time you drink it it's cold. And finally, you might think the beverage is too
hot, and indeed it is, so you wait to drink it, and then by the time you do,
it's perfect. Now put A, B, C, or D, in the respective boxes it belongs here,
and remember what H not, and H a are.